[Music]
i mentioned that you are five and a half
months
thank you for bringing that up i am just
pregnant and and uh
i would think i know when my wife went
through this we have two kids
she would wake me up at night and have
crazy dreams intense crazy dreams it's
something about the hormones being uh
being being pregnant are you going
through that i'm so going through this i
wake up and bore my husband every
morning with my dream i've had a
frequent dream where i'm killing someone
and i had a dream where i was killing a
woman and she was broken into pieces and
i just kept hammering in her face i
don't know what this means this is awful
what
you can't see but right now i'm hitting
a button under my desk
security is rushing in here quickly what
do you mean you have a frequent i don't
know i think dream where you're killing
people yeah where does that come from
i have this dream where i'm killing
someone i think i'm afraid of making a
mistake or something or i'm gonna do
something bad as a parent but i have
this dream where i kill someone and
sometimes it's a woman sometimes it's a
dragon sometimes i have no idea i i just
what are you eating what are you eating
just before you go to bed too much spicy
food okay that whole thing where you
don't eat spicy food when you're
pregnant oh no i take it down so there's
a lot of i know what i'm getting from
this and i'm not a a therapist yet but
i'm working on yourself getting my
license um you sound angry are you an
angry person i i mean i definitely don't
seem like an angry person but you say
you have frequent dreams of murder well
i am half murder i am half korean and we
do have something that my girlfriend
informed me of is called k rage has
anyone ever heard this i've not heard of
korean rage um i don't know where it
comes from but i think there's a lot of
drinking involved but
i definitely have a temper uh it's i'm
so mellow now now that i'm pregnant and
i'm married i'm happy so there's no way
but you're saying that uh this is
something that's in korean culture where
you get angry there's just like a like a
temper that people think of asians as
really docile but koreans are quite
fiery and and quite fierce in their in
their temperament so i definitely have
like k-rage and my girlfriend's always
like you know don't go north korean on
me when i lose my temper really
she's like listen kk which means crazy
korean yeah
what a very understanding friend you
have this is my best friend
who's your friend don rickles you know
calm down there kkk
uh
you know it's funny because uh well i
know that i am irish as you can imagine
well
i have a there's an irish rage that i
have but the irish don't do anything
with it
you know it all like gets internalized
into weird passive-aggressive behavior
lots of heartburn yeah a lot of
heartburn everything but it sounds like
you act on your rage or at least you do
in your dreams where you smash people's
faces so i think i work it out in my
dream like you know i karate chop and
kill someone and then i you know i wake
up in the day and i'm ready to go but i
think i work it out in my dreams but
it's normal i think in pregnancy to have
well maybe it's not normal to kill
people in your dreams no i've never
heard that before i think you're maybe
i read dr spock and there's no murder
dreams
yeah well i guess you're not pregnant
and that releases a lot
i don't think pregnancy has ever been
used as an excuse for murder fantasies i
use it as an excuse for everything when
i want to eat like a breakfast burrito
my husband's like it is not your
pregnancy you just want to eat bad food
right yeah no i have an older brother
who's clearly been pregnant for like 15
years
it's for the baby
what baby
um okay we have a we have a clip here
from falling skies
a terrific show
there's been an alien invasion and and
you play a doctor who's really trying to
help people i play a former pediatrician
and i think in this scene i'm helping
one of the soldiers who's injured and
all hell breaks loose okay let's take a
look at this clip from fallen skies
just to help us get them upstairs
no i'm not leaving you
this is weird
what
these holes weren't here before
matt don't come here
oh
[Applause]
well
we
i think we crack where the bad dreams
are coming from
i don't understand it
it must be what i'm eating just before i
go to bed what did you do at work today
honey oh i saw aliens crawl out of a
corpse
i'm so used to it
but still i think it's the breakfast
sandwich